[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est avec nous jusqu'à 9h30 sa salade
grec sera disponible dès demain sur
Netflix Siri
alors c'est devenu une telle star que
même Netflix a réagi regardez le chat
était invité à visiter les locaux de la
plateforme au Royaume-Uni et la
plateforme a fait un poisson d'avril en
faisant croire et bac elle avait
remplacé le célèbre tadam par le miaou
de Sawyer voilà ce que ça donne
[Musique]
les manifestants veulent se faire
entendre des 9 sages qui demain rendront
leur décision sur la constitutionnalité
de la réforme des retraites non pas sur
sa raison d'être mais sur ces modalités
juridiques le bâtiment est sous bonne
garde tout comme le Conseil d'État tout
proche pas question que des institutions
soient prises pour cible
alors dans le défilé parisien cet
après-midi certains veulent encore
croire à une censure du texte
[Musique]
aujourd'hui alors qui sont les 9 sages
du Conseil alors les plus connus sont
deux anciens Premiers ministres Laurent
Fabius qui préside le conseil depuis 7
ans et Alain Juppé il y a aussi deux
anciens ministres d'Emmanuel Macron
Jacques mesard et Jacqueline Gouraud et
5 haut fonctionnaires ils ont tous été
nommés par le Président de la République
du Sénat ou de l'Assemblée 6 hommes 3
femmes moyennes d'âge 72 ans presque
tous issus de la vie politique donc
évidemment cette forme
particulière nous intrigue mais ce qui
nous intrigue plus c'est lui
à quoi sert cet objet Emmanuel Macron
quant à lui a promis d'échanger avec les
syndicats une fois que le Conseil
constitutionnel aura donné sa réponse le
président affirme vouloir le faire dans
un esprit de concorde et une volonté de
s'engager pour la suite quelle que soit
la décision des sages je proposerai en
effet un ensemble des partenaires
sociaux que nous puissions avoir un
échange
qui constatera nous le savons bien des
désaccords avec l'exécutif mais qui
permettra aussi d'engager la suite et de
tenir compte des décisions quelles
qu'elles soient du Conseil
constitutionnel j'avais envie de dire
lol en fait c'est à dire bon c'est bien
que tout d'un coup il est envie de
rencontrer les syndicats sachant que ça
fait un mois qu'on lui a demandé un
rendez-vous et qui nous l'a refusé le
problème c'est l'heure du jour c'est que
nous lors du jour du rendez-vous avec
Emmanuel Macron c'est le retrait de
cette réforme des retraites là en fait
il nous propose un hors sujet on va pas
passer à autre chose faut pas croire que
les gens allaient travailleurs et
travailleuses qui se mobilisent qui sont
contre cette réforme depuis des mois
vont passer comme ça autre chose ça ne
marche pas c'est pas comme ça que ce
traite les citoyens et les citoyens et
notamment le monde du travail donc quand
il y aura un délai de décence je le dis
très clairement et les retraites là le
problème des retraites c'est 10% du
problème le problème il est beaucoup
plus profond déjà pensons au salaire ils
sont trop minimes en France par rapport
à tout ce qui se passe maintenant et là
c'est vraiment un seul j'en ai ras le
bob voilà de la folie
il est 6h du matin quand une vingtaine
d'hommes armés cagoulés à tout à l'heure
des boules chez le couple de retraités
on est arrivé tout de suite ici en
faisant ce qui se passait ils ont dit
c'est la police ils ont poussé contre le
mur avec en nous disant les mains en
l'air des membres du raid se mettent à
fouiller la maison par ici là ils sont
montés dans les étages puis moi j'étais
comme ça avec les mains en l'air avec le
l'un des un des hommes qui me tenait en
joue
il y a les faits de panique on est
tétanisé on est complètement on est
tremblant on a été questionné sans
bouger et quand on a répondu donner
notre adresse réelle c'est là une en dit
ah ouais on s'est trompé d'adresse et le
chef a rappelé Sega et ils sont repartis
aussi rapidement qu'ils étaient venus
est-ce que vous vous souvenez la
première fois ben oui quand même de
cette chanson oui je crois oui
non est-ce que vous souvenez de votre
première fois mais que quoi que vous
êtes venus sur ce plateau
non je parle sur ce plateau
non j'ai pas fait ça une dizaine de
minutes surréalistes pour les deux
retraités en pyjama davantage amusés que
traumatisé à peine ils étaient partis
mais on n'en ont rien c'est pas possible
tellement on riait on rit on rit et puis
forcément on a beaucoup d'enfants donc
on a envoyé ça sur les WhatsApp famille
avec nos enfants les cousins et alors
chacun y aller de son Commentaire donc
maintenant c'est vraiment
presque un bon souvenir plutôt que
qu'une angoisse vous croyez capable de
tout mais pas de celui de vous poser en
victime un homme qui dit MiTo moi aussi
je suis une victime c'est pas forcément
le discours le plus pourquoi d'audible
du moment pourquoi pas
laissez-moi aller jusqu'au vous allez
nous expliquer parce que
rebelle Monseigneur Gaillot évêque
contestataire qui a défendu la cause des
divorcés des homosexuels et des immigrés
au sein de l'Église est mort à l'âge de
87 ans des suit d'une maladie fulgurante
et avec des vrais pendant 13 ans le
Vatican lui avait retiré sa charge en
janvier 1995 en raison les positions non
orthodoxes au sein de l'Église je
trouvais que vous vous faisiez tout pour
qu'on vous déteste et que vous faisiez
tout pour être Inaudi pour agacer pour
vous être vraiment un sale gosse mais
c'est vrai mais c'est depuis toujours et
c'est bizarre maintenant quand je vais
dans des émissions je me fais gronder
comme si j'avais 8 ans
je peux comprendre qu'ils veulent pas me
pardonner mais je veux dire voilà je
vais pas tout raconter ici et voilà
exemple c'est que voilà genre la tartine
au caca c'était moi
[Rires]
je vais lui vous m'avez agacé envie
j'avais envie de vous tirer sur les
cheveux aussi mais j'avais envie de vous
poser des questions j'avais envie que
vous m'expliquiez vous le faites de
façon sincère effectivement ça dérangera
ça ne plaira pas mais c'est un ça reste
un livre un objet de littérature mais
j'arrive quand même à découvrir une
forme c'est la Joconde
[Musique]
ce chef-d'oeuvre de la Renaissance dans
sa précipitation il s'est complètement
emmené les pinceaux il a donné le nom du
peintre impressionniste Monet au lieu de
l'italien Léonard de Vinci